you know as a humble man who prefers to
shrink from the spotlight it pains me to
have to start another show saying i told
you so but i did in fact tell you so you
may remember a few weeks ago when andrew
cuomo had finally been pushed to resign
from the governorship and many on the
right were throwing the confetti and
cheering his demise and i said that we
should slow the celebratory parade down
a little bit it is certain that whoever
replaces him will be worse you know one
thing that we ought to understand about
the left at this point is that they
never i mean never ever not ever turn on
one of their own as they did cuomo
unless
they've got a more dedicated and radical
ideologue waiting in the wings to
replace him that's the only time they do
it the media after months of hero
worship suddenly decided to hold cuomo
accountable i mean how could this be
explained was it a case of sudden onset
integrity had they seen the light were
they determined out of nowhere to be
fair objective and honest were the media
and democrats trying to oust cuomo
simply because he deserved to be ousted
no obviously not they were doing it
because they realized it would benefit
them and part of the reason why i would
benefit them is that the person who
would replace him kathy hokule
huckle
hocule i'll go with a bunch of different
pronunciations because i don't know
would be an even more reliable pawn for
the far left hocal is a particularly
dangerous type of tyrant she's a
thoroughly mediocre woman unimpressive
in every way very few accomplishments to
her name who managed to float on the
breeze into a position of power she
served one unremarkable term in congress
nearly a decade ago before losing
reelection next thing you know she's
appointed lieutenant governor and now
she's governor of one of the most
populated states in the country
these are always the types you have to
look out for much like camila harris who
made her way into politics by sleeping
with a married man and then became vice
president despite losing in the
primaries in spectacular fashion
garnering essentially zero support from
the electorate
these are these are these are the types
who along with being communists
also think they have something to prove
and kathy halcule has set out to prove
whatever it is she wants to prove
yesterday she announced that all
healthcare workers in the state had to
be vaccinated by midnight or be fired
listen to this
we'll be nation leading with our
mandate which strikes at midnight
tonight when everyone is expected in the
hospital in the state of new york or
health care facility to have been
vaccinated i will be signing an
executive order to give me the emergency
powers necessary to address the
shortages where they occur that's going
to allow me to
deploy the national guard who are
medically trained
deploy people uh who've been retired who
may have had a licensed lapse bring in
people from elsewhere that is not my
first position of my friends my my
desire is to have the people who've been
out there continue to work in their jobs
working them safely and to all the other
health care workers who are vaccinated
they also deserve to know that the
people they're working with will not get
them sick
okay so just to be clear about what's
happening here the governor of new york
is artificially engineering a hospital
staffing shortage
while at the same time claiming that
we're in the middle of a deadly pandemic
and hospitals are overwhelmed hospitals
are overwhelmed so let's uh start firing
healthcare workers by the hundreds or
thousands
this is without exaggeration one of the
most twisted and evil things we've ever
seen
she's also made it clear that there will
be no religious exemptions for any
healthcare worker who refuses the jab
and she makes i guess this is her legal
argument for
disallowing religious exemptions and i
find it i don't know a little bit
dubious listen to this
my default position is to ask people
please do this
this is why
it's been proven to be safe the
vaccine's been out there a long time now
there are not legitimate religious
exemptions because the leaders of all
the organized religions have said
there's no legitimate reason and we're
going to win that in court in a matter
of days
and so this is so unnecessary
and i just want to appeal to the
individuals to know that you know your
co-workers want you to do this
don't make the burden heavier on them as
well
so her legal argument for abolishing
religious exemptions is that she has
conducted a survey of the leaders of all
of the organized religions all of them
and found that all of them agree with
her
even if that were true of course it
would still would not negate religious
exemptions the opinions of religious
leaders don't supersede the first
amendment rights of individuals but
it's also not true i mean there are
something like 4 000 religions in the
world when she says that all of the
leaders of all of the religions agree
with her she means that she talked to
three episcopal priests and a rabbi
um her arguments may be laughable that
but that doesn't matter as we've seen
time and again she is simply going to
impose herself
claim power and exercise it regardless
of what anybody says about it is there
any actual reason any any good reason i
mean to fire thousands of healthcare
workers the very workers who were being
celebrated as living saints only six
months ago
have these unvaccinated healthcare
workers caused any outbreaks in the
intervening months
i haven't heard about that no one's
telling us about that so if they haven't
that means they've been working in
hospitals for 18 months without any
problem
why make it a problem now
and what about those healthcare workers
who understand the science as you'd hope
they all do though you hope in vain and
haven't gotten the vaccine because
they've already been infected and they
know that natural immunity likely
provides greater protection than the
vaccine according to
uh
the studies we've seen on this
why should they get the jet should they
be compelled to inject a substance into
their bodies just to what be good team
players
is that the argument
there is no response to these questions
those in power don't need to bother with
these kinds of questions at all or
responses to them they simply do what
they want to do and inflict the
punishment on anybody who defies them
this is about obedience religious
obedience
and hokiel made a cl made that clear a
few days earlier while speaking at a
mega church in new york this is pretty
incredible listen to this
but i prayed a lot to god during this
time and you know what
god did answer our prayers he made the
smartest men and women the scientists
the doctors the researchers he made them
come up with a vaccine that is from god
to us
and we must say thank you god thank you
and i wear my vaccinated necklace all
the time to say i'm vaccinated all of
you
yes i know you're vaccinated you're the
smart ones but you know there's people
out there who aren't listening to god
and what god wants you know this
you know who they are
i need you to be my apostles i need you
to go out and talk about it and say we
owe this to each other we love each
other
jesus taught us to love one another
and how do you show that love
but to care about each other enough to
say please get vaccinated because i love
you i want you to live i want our kids
to be safe when they're in schools i
want you to be safe when you go to a
doctor's office or to a hospital and are
treated by somebody you don't want to
get the
virus from them you're already sick or
you wouldn't be there
we have to solve this my friends
i need every one of you i need you to
let them know that this is how we can
get fight this pandemic come back to
normal and then start talking about the
real issues that we have to fighting
systemic racial injustice which exists
today and if there's a denier i will
take you on any date because i've seen
it i know it exists and we are not going
to have a blind eye to this ever again
any longer under my watch
oh she'll take you on hackle is going to
take you on
so hackle has a little bit of democrat
tourette syndrome at the end they're
shouting about systemic racism because
these people can't speak for more than
90 seconds without using the term
systemic racism but her statements
before that were revealing
she says that the vaccine is from god
except that really the vaccine is from
the pharmaceutical industry
and the mandates are from the government
it makes you wonder who god even is
according to her usage
well she clears that up quickly by
imploring the congregation to go out and
be my apostles she the governor of new
york is recruiting apostles her own
apostles not apostles of christ they're
urged to go out and find the lost sheep
and bring the sheep into the fold and
convince the sheep to stick a needle in
their arms and inject a drug into it
whether they need it or not
why well her religious framing i think
is quite appropriate this is about
religious observance obedience not to
god the real god the one true god but to
the god of the state
as far as the members of the coveted
cult are concerned the vaccine is a
sacrament getting the vaccine is a
sacramental act
at least that's how they see it
as a sign of fidelity and obedience to
the state that's why they insist that
children receive it even though their
immune system already provides them with
incredibly effective protection from the
virus
and they insist that people with natural
immunity get it
everybody else get it
whether they need it or not
because it's not about needs it's not
about health it's not about science it's
about compliance
that should be very obvious by now
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated